on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
tonight on Piers Morgan uncensored a
jaw-dropping world exclusive is one of
the defining musicians of his generation
and one of the most controversial people
alive tonight I'll go head to head with
the artist formerly known as Kanye West
from New York this is Piers Morgan
uncensored
well good evening welcome to a special
edition of Piers Morgan uncensored from
New York Kanye West now known simply as
yay one-on-one
[Music]
foreign
ing artists of his generation with 24
Grammys and more than 160 million
records sold producer
fashion designer billionaire the artist
formerly known as Kanye West is quite
simply a mega star yeah he's six year
marriage to Kim Kardashian made them
both Titans of the tabloids I had to go
to La and come back so I just traveled
to get something for Kev
thank you for Kanye and for his
unbelievable way he does things and the
ability to get something done but lately
it's his opinions that are stolen the
headlines thirsty wore White lives
matter t-shirt of the Paris fashion show
next he shot the world with a series of
anti-Semitic terrains including a tweet
threatening Defcon 3 on Jewish people
now suspended from social media and with
his Adidas deal in Jeopardy yeah has
doubled down
spreading unfounded conspiracy theories
about George Floyd which is now being
sued by the family if you look the guy's
knee wasn't even on his neck like that
is he malicious is he misunderstood is
he just a racist or is he mentally
unwell tonight yay gets a chance to set
the record straight yay is one of the
most influential people on the planet of
that there's no doubt he's just
announced that he's buying the social
media platform parlor he has physical
Ambitions too and because of his profile
his recent offensive comments have
called Global outrage as well as ongoing
speculation about his health well
tonight I give yay the opportunity to
explain and perhaps reconsider or maybe
even apologize for some of those
comments some of the things he says in
this interview are in my opinion
anti-semitic and defensive we're airing
them in the context of an interview in
which I try to understand why he made
his comments what he really meant by
them and whether he understands the
anger that his words have caused what
follows is a gripping fiery shocking
sometimes funny sometimes Bonkers
interview and at the end of it you can
make your own mind up about yay yay
thank you very much indeed for joining
Piers Morgan uncensored my first
question for you I guess is an obvious
one what do you hope to achieve from our
conversation
uh that right there being uncensored
in American Media it's very censored
it's it feels like an episode of Black
Mirror a lot of times so I've put myself
across the line the point the point of
no return saying hey I know they're
going to say whatever they want about me
when I bring up the truth they're gonna
say you didn't get enough sleep it's
because of your health they're going to
call me names for my truth but these
experiences that I'm telling you about
are factually things that I've went
through and things that I refuse to keep
going through and things that I'm not
going to let my children go through and
things that I'm not going to let my
peers go through no pun intended well
look we are most certainly uncensored on
this show yay and I want to give you the
time and the platform to really explain
yourself because I think that sometimes
sound bites about people uh perhaps take
another context sometimes can create a
very disturb view of what a person
really thinks what do you think looking
back over the last few weeks in
particular what do you think have been
the biggest misconceptions about you
well I think there's a left agenda to
silence anyone that goes against the
agenda let's go back to Trump running
for office
back in 2015 everyone that was around me
in my industry in the entertainment
industry told me that my life would be
over I would be on the wrong side of
History I've even had threats to my life
for wearing the Trump hat and it even
ended up in you know destroying my
family and also making it where I have
to raise my children differently because
I actually am
uh a person that's classified as black
you know I classify myself as Jew uh but
uh a person is classified that had been
given that title in America as black in
America that I'm supposed to stay in a
block of a vote you never heard the term
white vote so why is there a term black
vote how is that okay it sounds just as
racist as a black drinking fountain and
I'm my dad you know called me and said
you know the thing that the left
fear about yay or makes me the most
dangerous is I'm rich
and that's the point Tupac told me back
in the days you know you had to get your
money right and then you go to war so
I'm going to war you know I don't I
don't have I don't have endless
resources I only have like maybe a you
know honestly only maybe 120 million
dollars in my account but what I'm not
going to let happen is I'm not going to
let my kids take over Yeezy someday and
have a boardroom telling them what to do
and talking behind their back I'm not
going to let that happen to my children
so I have to fight right now and the
other powerful icons in black music when
they are at the top of the game they
didn't fight at that point they were too
afraid of losing whatever they had so
people have to understand just The
Bravery there's so many people
everywhere I know everyone can relate to
being afraid to say what you're going to
feel because you feel like you're gonna
you know you're going to lose something
so whether you agree with me or not
I believe people are going to feel the
fact that someone is brave enough to say
something every day I do five things
that people have been historically
killed for every day and it's just yo I
want to prove first of all I am Jew also
the 12 lost tribes of Hebrew do the math
do your research on it we have got our
culture ripped from us and then told we
were just simply void of color which is
another definition for black
but if we knew we were a culture and
knew we were a people the way the Jewish
people know then we wouldn't abort
ourselves we wouldn't shoot each other
dead in the streets and then rap about
it we wouldn't uh brag about you know
having sex with each other's wives we
would keep our families together and we
would do business together most
dangerous place for a black person in
America is actually in our mother's
stomachs because 50 percent of black
deaths a year in America is abortion
currently
I mean I can keep going but I want to
make it hey boom
I don't want to jump in too much because
I here's what I honestly think I think
you have an extraordinary mind you have
a number of extraordinary talents you're
a musical genius you're a fascinating
public figure uh what has been
interesting to me is to watch the fury
which has erupted in the last few weeks
over a series of statements that you've
made which of course as you know a lot
of offense and I guess before I get into
them I'm just curious as to
whether you think there is a line for
free speech I listen I completely agree
with you that there is a war against
free speech that people are you know
treading on eggshells all the time
terrified of expressing honestly held
opinions in case they get canceled I
think we're living in a really Insidious
era where Liberals are behaving like
fascists so on that you have absolutely
my agreement but my question for you is
do you believe there are limits to free
speech and if they are what are they
there are no limits to free speech it's
all context right Tarantino can write a
movie about slavery where actually him
and Jamie they got the idea from me
because the idea for Django I pitched to
Jamie Foxx and Quentin Tarantino as the
video for gold digger uh and then
Tarantino turned into a film
but in that film he puts a contact he he
creates a context where Leonardo
DiCaprio has allowed to use the word
multiple times within that context so
Hollywood's job is to frame things and
they allow what context what what
content is accepted and what's not we
have our thoughts that you know everyone
has thoughts and ideas and then people
try to manipulate your thoughts and
ideas in order for Humanity to move
forward we have to be free to think and
then to actualize I like the word
actualized better than uh execute if you
think about executes the negative
negative word actualized to be more
positive except for the fact it has the
word act in it and everyone's an actor
especially in Hollywood I'm as I'm like
top five writers in human exist in human
history so I really get into the way the
Power of Words and I feel very akin to
Capote e Freud
Nikolai Tesla Da Vinci Matisse more
Matisse than Picasso more African cubism
than Matisse so I just do that I thought
that's kind of for the Liberals and
that's the funny thing it's like uh
liberals
when you say you're more when you say
you're more Matisse than Picasso as
somebody who's a fan of Matisse and
Picasso she'll spend a lot of time in in
Santa Fe where they all used to paint
together
um why do you say a Matisse what is it
about Matisse that you feel an affinity
with
I think I feel like Drake is more
Picasso and yay is more Matisse when we
talked about
and when me and Drake went to do the
show last year uh for a prison reform
and to bring awareness to the uh
incarceration of Larry Hoover I sent him
articles about the relationship of
Matisse and Picasso and the need for
these people you you need to have that
you know I need to go into the bar
and go to Starbucks that's a you know
that's a form of a modern day bar right
and just hear Drake's song playing back
to back and Drake needs to go into that
same Starbucks just in a different city
and see people wearing Yeezys God does
this to remind us that we are not God
because when you take people like Elon
Musk and Bernardino
and uh Trump or uh Jack ma uh Putin you
take these people in their own space in
their own environments you know we can
start to feel like God's on Earth but we
are nothing in comparison to God and we
are here actually to love one another
and to collaborate and to make the world
a better place there's you know one
percent of the world are placed in power
and 99 of the world are the audience so
that one percent of the world this idea
of the United Nations this is the world
that needs to come together this is is
the world that I mean here's the obvious
go-to Biden doesn't listen to Elon Musk
the president of the United States does
not have meetings with Elon Musk that is
hey here come come come get me that's
[ __ ]
I know I'm not supposed to say that
Biden but that's [ __ ] Biden and and
I you know it's
um
and obviously because I've been deemed
with mental health all this I have the
right to use whatever words that I like
to use well that's interesting so
somebody ask you another question well
yeah let me ask you on that so you just
you just said something very
inflammatory about President Biden it
will as you know offend a lot of people
and it will particularly offend people
who work in mental health who say you
should not use a word like [ __ ] but
you say that because you yourself have
had mental health issues that entitles
you to use that kind of word as an
insult now I would say that's an
arguable Point I've had my issue my
issue is I've had mental health
allegations
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
do you believe that you have any form of
mental illness
I believe that I suffered from
exhaustion
I believe that I suffered from
exhaustion I suffered from being lied to
constantly by the people around me and I
believe those things can drive anyone to
a point of Maximum exhaustion
but I also believe that I'm extremely
brilliant and I'm here to make the world
a better place and I'm tired of the left
media trying to pick on me
and y'all picked on me enough and y'all
y'all finally touched the person
that's not going to stand that's not
going to take it anymore
and that's part of the reason why I'm on
uncensored because what they'd like is
for me to be quiet interesting thing
about racism and cancer culture is kind
of similar right
it racism
works on itself I can go into the Gucci
store age 18 and I just assume that
people think that I'm about to steal so
I buy more things with cancer culture
when I brought Marilyn Manson on stage
with me when he was dealing with
allegations my stepbrother Marilyn was
canceling herself what they had so many
people comment on my white lives matter
t-shirt there's people who are saying
right there on Fashion Week when are you
going home I'm so afraid people thought
I was going to cancel myself I'm not
going to cancel myself I'm going to keep
on delivering what I feel because guess
what it's very split opinions by the way
if I talk to a black person that makes
under a million dollars a year they
really are they really relate to the
George Floyd comments and feel hurt that
I would even
uh bring it up and question the approach
they have multiple documentaries on the
death of JFK but we're just supposed to
believe this one media Outlet version
that prayed on our trauma and our pain
and then if I talk to Rich black people
uh or white people Jew or Catholic or
atheists they're really into the Jewish
media com uh comment because it affects
their business interests okay well it
was really interesting let me just pick
you up on the two things you mentioned
the first one is what you said about
George Floyd and the reality of that
it's not a media interpretation of how
he died because the Hennepin County
chief medical examiner concluded that
Floyd died from cardiopulmonary arrest
his heart stopped Complicated by the way
the police restrained him and compressed
his neck now he also said there were
other contributing conditions let me
finish there were other contributing
conditions narrowed arteries high blood
pressure and Fentanyl intoxication but
although these were significant
conditions he said and things that
played a role in the death they didn't
directly cause the death the cause of
death was what that policeman did that
person well why would the coroner lie
what makes you believe that why would
the current a lie because he could get
paid to lie because he could get paid to
lie because I watched it I watched it
but the majority of the press right but
I watched it for eight minutes have you
seen the the Candace Owens BLM
documentary I have watched uh some of
that documentary but here's what I would
say to you when you watch that video of
George Floyd no it's not a butt it's not
it's that I want you to watch I I know I
know
wait I'm gonna finish
I know what it means
be quiet and let me finish Bobby you did
interrupt my question so with the BLM no
I wasn't I wasn't finished your present
agenda you haven't seen the whole thing
so we can have 20 different perspectives
on how JFK died but us as black people
not only are can we only vote one way
we're not allowed to have any other
perspectives and that the area for
George Floyd where he passed the murder
rate is up 50 percent and nothing this
is so-called movement but it didn't move
blacks anywhere right now listen like a
person I will say there are legitimate
questions about the black lives matter
movement no question but on the specific
point about how George Floyd died I
don't think it's in question about what
actually killed him it was that police
officer
what is in question it isn't it isn't
question I'm questioning person what
you're questioning is a coroner report I
said hey are do you do you have friends
that were killed by police officers do
you have friends that were locked up do
you have friends do you have uh people
aborting half your race no so I am the
black person with the black experience
that's worth 11 billion dollars and is
the most influential person on the
planet and I am questioning it okay you
and I have a right to question you
absolutely you can't tell me you can't
tell me you can't tell me with your
accent that me as an American Jew black
person that I cannot question that deaf
and question the means he had I'm not
I'm just put on camera I'm not saying
you're too traumatized I'm not feeling
la la la la I mean so let me finish okay
I'm not finished talking so we can't I
cannot I see because you distract my
thoughts and then you try to make me
look like a crazy person and you feel
you have the right to cut me off and
I've proven you you guys don't want it
with me this is like Terminator 20.
you've never seen this before you've
never seen this before so I want no one
to play with me I have the right to
question because that videotape was used
to traumatize my people and force us
into the Democratic vote hey George
Soros you're a real competitor I respect
you I'm worth more money than you and I
have more influence in you and have you
know Pierce Morgan from a different
country saying well the uh I'm not going
to do an English accent because that
would be racist uh I'm funny by the way
uh that's fine you can do that I thought
I said to you it's always uncensored yet
you can say what the hell you like right
but that doesn't mean I can't pick you
up on a few things right you accept that
I accept that but you try to say it is
unquestionable because this one Dr faucy
said this I know it wasn't Dr faucy but
I'm just giving an example where we hear
from even Google like people feel like
you know if you Google it it's factual
there's so much non-factual information
about me on Google but then I still
believe Google and people pay to get
certain information to the top of Google
but this is good this is keep going what
else you want to go with it
the civil rights lawyer Lee Merritt
responded to what you said about George
Floyd's death and said while one cannot
defame the Dead the family of George
Floyd is considering suit which they're
now doing as you know they're suing you
for 250 million dollars for yay's full
statements about the manner of his death
claiming Floyd died from fentanyl not
the brutality established criminally and
civilly undermines and diminishes the
Floyd family's fight so what is your
response to that
will anybody who loses a loved one my
heart goes out to them any race my heart
goes out to the pain of that I have a
theory about it now this is not a fact
this is a feeling that I have in the
documentary George Floyd's two roommates
said that George kept saying they want a
tall guy like me they want a tall guy
like me so for me I'm a creative right I
can like make a dinosaur out of a femur
right so
if I'm making a dinosaur out of a femur
and I'm looking at a documentary that
says George Floyd was telling his two
roommates they want a tall guy like me
and on the day of his death he prayed
for eight minutes they said he prayed
longer than he ever prayed what do you
think me as a creative mind the
beautiful mind right the sensitive mind
what do you think I feel could have
happened in that situation all right
well honestly if I'm being honest with
you I would say that because of your
brilliant beautiful creative mind as you
put in I don't dispute that at all
you've got an extraordinary mind and I
can see that in the way that you conduct
interviews you go off on very long
tangents but they're sort of fascinating
I find it fascinating to listen to you
I'm not saying you don't have a right
these are like Capote
motivating tangents I'm just saying it's
it's a way you you conduct yourself and
I think that's very interesting well you
mean it's I already know not why why is
it oh it's not Capote level
if you sort of if you would like this to
compare you to Truman Capote I am fat I
am happy to do that yay if you want to
be known as the new Capote I'm with you
okay I'm not going to question your
talent your talent to me is completely
unquestionable right when you question
that the question about the femur to the
dinosaur no I'm going to ask you a
different situation I'm just going to
ask you this what no you're not you're
gonna you're gonna know I didn't finish
my question well hang on you can't tell
me answer my question you can't tell me
what questions to ask you you accept
that I'm the interview answer my
question no I said answer my question no
I'm interviewing you too well you can't
interview me it's my interview
your Bono I'm interviewing you too see
that's the way we wrap it let me just
you're gonna say no no let me just let
me just put this so no no no no no no
you're trying to you no no no no no no
no no
friends
all right you can but let me because you
haven't answered my question here's my
question for you but you have an answer
no I'm not answer don't and don't answer
my don't ask answer my question yeah I'm
not answering anything I'm going back to
my original question in a way which is
simply this I'm not saying you don't
have a right to question how George
Floyd died but given the world watch
that horrifying video of that
policeman's knee on his neck and given
that is what the coroner said caused his
death albeit he had other underlying
conditions including fentanyl
intoxication
when the family see someone like you
who's hugely influential you you're
known around the world questioning how
their loved one died they find that very
hurtful which is why they're now suing
you for it and my question for you is do
you understand the pain that sometimes
your comments can cause like this this
circumstance with George Floyd's family
now I'm going to ask you a question
again
with my imagination if you see when you
see in the documentary that George
Floyd's two roommates said he said they
want a tall guy like me they want a tall
guy like me and that he prayed extra
long on the day of his passing where do
you think that takes my beautiful mind I
think it can take you to a place where
you want to believe something which may
not be true I'm not saying it's not I'm
just saying all the evidence
answer my honest answer is I think that
they wonder that was a that was a
political collection my honest belief my
honest belief is it what do you guys do
what do you I mean people in The
Newsroom what are they doing they're
like cringing right now they're like
whoa no we never experience no we never
experience I'm not cringing black
entertainer that won't be threatened by
the media to back down from his opinion
yeah I think you missed yourself you
must date me for somebody who's going to
be like the others I have a show called
unsensitive for a reason I'm giving you
a platform for a reason but you're
pressing an agenda no no I'm not you're
perfectly entitled to your opinions but
do you accept Humane now do you accept
you may not always be right I just I I
just called you I just called you a liar
how does that make you that's fine if
you think I'm a liar it's fine
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
you're a liar you're pressing the agenda
of the pain and Trauma and Trauma
economy that is pressed on my people by
the left
actually the trauma I think that was
implemented to George Floyd was somebody
a vile white racist police officer who
need him to his death and I agree with
the coroner's findings because I don't
see any reason why the coroner would
invent that so that's my belief if you
want to challenge that and you don't
believe it that's entirely you're right
I have a question who do you think are
the biggest vowel white racist the media
you think the media is racist
what please next question please don't
ask me any [ __ ] questions
okay let me go to the the next Fury
which has been around you in the last
couple of weeks which is your attention
is that is that is that is that is that
is that British for theory is that
British foot Theory
what's Theory bro is that British for
Theory you actually have quite a good
British accent
that's quite good let me ask you yeah if
I can about the allegations that you
have made anti-semitic comments and in
particular when you said on Instagram
I'm a bit sleepy tonight but when I wake
up I'm going Defcon 3 on Jewish people
now many people who are Jewish found
that deeply offensive they wanted to
know what what did you mean by going
Defcon 3 on Jewish people because Defcon
3 as you know is a heightened state of
awareness for military action so what
did you mean by that what was is your
chance to clarify what you meant by
Defcon 3 on Jewish people
well thank you for allowing me to say
what I meant due to the fact that I was
blocked by Jewish people after I said
that so it wasn't actually allowed to
say what I was about to say uh but what
I was gonna say is
I was going to talk about all of the
contracts
all of the missed dealings that I dealt
with as an Entertainer being that I'm an
Entertainer I've been wronged so many
times by Jewish businessmen and the
reason why I say people if a black man
is caught in the car with drugs or a gun
and there's three other black guys in
the car with them guess what they're all
going to jail so the reason why I say
people is I want those businessmen's
wives and fathers mothers grandmothers
and kids to ask them why is yay so mad
at us because they're taking money out
of my children's mouths so I'm in a
point where I'm frustrated I have the
right to my anger and I'm saying that
people need to fix it I'm not going to
fix what I feel until what I'm feeling
is fixed okay can I respond that's just
gonna shut me me up and say no I'm not
going to shut you up can I respond to
what you just said
my problem with what you've said I'll be
straight with you is if I as a white man
posted tomorrow on my Instagram I'm a
bit sleepy tonight but when I wake up
I'm going Defcon 3 on black people
what would you think do you no no if I
said black people what would you think
if that was what I posted what did you
accept that black people you accepted
that black people are Jew or no but no
no no I'll come to that in a moment on
the specific note if I simply said in
other words all black people was the
implication of what I said I would get
rightly canceled I would get rightly
vilified and abused you I suspect would
be outraged by a white person saying
such a thing because you wouldn't make
any distinction about whether I was
talking about certain black business
people I'd fallen out with or whatever
you would think I was judging an entity
populace by the color of their skin You
Are by saying Jewish people on Jewish
people you're not saying Jewish
businessmen accountants whatever that
you've had a problem with you're
basically saying in that statement all
Jewish people which is why it caused
such offense and I'm curious whether you
even as you wrote those words understood
what Jewish people actually would feel
when you said that and didn't make any
uh specific references to any
individuals
maybe they would feel how all my people
have felt maybe they would feel the pain
of when a black artist looks up and
they've been completely they've
completely been raped by five Jewish
businessmen and there's multiple
accounts why does the fact that they're
Jewish have anything to do and feel like
that but why why would you say it just
so happens they are well okay but I
wouldn't why categorize them according
to their religious Faith their ethnicity
why we do that why can't you just
describe them as business people that
you've dealt with
that's fine but what you're doing by
saying Jewish people these constant
tiradesier against Jewish people
that sounds like you have it I think
it's a Time where's the tirade that was
just that was a tweet it was a tweet
you asked me to explain it and that have
you felt my pain yet you haven't felt my
pain I've I just want to feel myself I
know you don't hold a counter la la la
la la la la you don't hold
accountability to my pain you're being a
Karen I'm talking about I'm talking
about
the pain I'm not a Karen I'm not going
to cancel you and I'm not going to
uncens you I'm simply going to challenge
you on what you're saying I think you
don't understand the pain that you've
been causing with some of these comments
and I think that one in particular I can
understand God God
forbid God forbid one comment could
cause people to feel any of the pain
that my people have went through for
years even like the blacks being ushered
to the left during the Civil Rights
Movement no one is cared okay
I don't know all right no one is can I
let me say I agree that the racism
against black people has been utterly
deplorable shameful unacceptable and
thank God the world is beginning to move
to a better place
people like you however however one form
of racism
I'm not cutting you off I'm finishing my
sentence so you can respond wonderful
racism
racism it is racism when you say I'm
going down
that's racism no it's not I thought I
thought I thought you I thought you had
I thought you had a a platform where I
could explain how I felt you don't care
about how I feel you just want to shut
me up you don't want me to say out loud
what my people have been going through I
do
or do I do I'm very happy so what if my
people have been going through what what
led me to that point
my question is me a person a successful
a successful influential extremely
extremely extremely attractive person to
get to that point
I am not doubting for a moment that you
will feel genuine pain about the racism
against you and other black people in
America not for one second
would I deny that racism by who by
anybody I think anything of racism is
wrong any form of racism is wrong I
don't I I didn't say I didn't say Defcon
or anybody though you said Defcon 3 on
Jewish people specifically Jewish people
you didn't say any particular Jewish
person you said basically all of them
that is racism yay and I think if you
were honest with yourself give them the
Fallout from this you would think again
about how you phrase that sentence
because actually you didn't mean all
Jewish people you didn't fall out
given the Fallout in the Fallout do you
care about the uh Jewish people fall out
well you were removed from that you were
removed from social media so the thing
is I want to bring joy to the world I'm
a composer right and this is a symphony
our life is a symphony we have so many
beautiful ideas but I feel the
anti-semite has been a wall a cloak that
allows Jewish businessmen boom I'll only
be the police officer that says hey this
guy with the gun is the only person
going to jail I'll be the first person
that does that in history right no one
else in this car riding with the guy
with the gun and the drugs is going to
jail are you happy I'll play by rules
that are not played by for my people
just for the sake of this I don't want
you playing by anything that makes you
happy right I don't want I don't want
you to say anything just to make me
happy that's what colonizers do is give
us rules I'm not trying to colonize
all I'm saying to you is when you use a
phrase yay like I'm going Defcon free on
Jewish people did you hear what I just
said that what you've just said is not
what you said on your Instagram post and
you know it right if you have a problem
with particular businessmen what do you
happen to what would you do that is a
concern for you and you know it talk
about it all Jewish brother can we
brother do you what is the point brother
do you want me to grow from the
statement I just told you okay I was in
a position where I've been hurt and this
is the way I had the right to express
myself the point of this interview is
for you to question me and then for me
to answer and say okay even though the
same rules are not apply to my people if
a person with a gun or drugs is pulled
over and has four three other people in
the car they're all going to jail I'm
not going to apply that to Jewish people
for the sake of this conversation isn't
that what you wanted but you know what
you did you tried to civil rights meet
you tried to pull me back to a week ago
but we're here today there's been plenty
of Commerce conversations of commentary
since that but you want me to go back to
1960. there's one way to go back to
seven days ago let me jump in here's
what I want you to do I want you to do
okay so have we grown have we how we
have we grabbed how we grew here's how
we grow I want you to reflect have we
grown I'm about to regrow I'm about in
charge of my growth okay like this I'm
about to suggest to you how you may grow
if you choose to grow this way and you
can you can ignore me you can ignore me
Pierce Pierce how much money are you
worth not as much as you sadly
exactly so take my advice maybe you'll
get richer I would love to take your
business why would I listen to you why
do you why do you hear what my advice is
and then work out if I'm wrong can we do
that deal
next tonight my world inclusive
interview with yay continues
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
you haven't given me any credit for a
moment of reflection for the comparison
that I made the brilliant if I do say so
myself comparison that I made to the
cops pulling over one black person and
locking up in my tweet having issues I
wasted I wasn't done with the sentence
my tweet referring to all Jewish people
I said for the sake of this conversation
I will refer to the business people who
have destroyed me and my people and my
fellow creatives but you didn't even
accept that I gave you that you tried to
push me back into 1960. no one tried to
push me back into last week no I didn't
okay I didn't accept that example that I
gave you I understand can completely the
example you gave me I think all racism
is wrong I just will that we've grown I
would like you to reflect if you've
grown if you feel we've grown if you've
now changed what you wanted to say
originally my question for you is do you
now regret saying
on Jewish people are you sorry you said
that
it matters you should be absolutely not
you should be absolutely not yeah but
yeah you should be absolutely not are
the are the people the Jewish
businessmen that led me to that place
are they sorry for the way they've raped
me I don't know who you're talking about
in particular but I don't know why you
keep having to say it what is the fact
they're Jewish got to do with anything
why do you keep what do you mean they're
the Jewish businessmen that did that
because they're business people that's
what they do why do you keep saying
Jewish business people why do you keep
using their religion their ethnicity why
they keep doing that let me update it
then okay okay so I'll say this
would it be would would I have grown
into the box you want me to go on if I
say to specify the business people that
have raped my people that just so
happened to be Jewish
I think what by doing what you've just
done I find that I'm not even Jewish and
I find that offensive why do you keep
having to do that I don't think you get
it at all I know you understand the
offense you're causing when you keep
using their religious background their
ethnicity so what does a stick to beat
them with why would you do that
so what are you more concerned about are
you more concerned about getting the
richest black man of all time the cow
tell because it's not going to happen I
don't want you to count so you can do
what the hell you like you're yay you're
you know a billionaire you can do what
the hell you want I'm just I'm just
saying to you that I don't think you
quite understand when you talk about uh
okay can I finish it's not uh multi
multi you're a multi-billionaire okay
well congratulations but that doesn't
change the fact that when you insult the
Jewish people and so you're going
Jessica 3 on the Jewish people that is
as racist as anything you say you've
been through and any pain that you've
experienced it's the same thing racism
is racism
and you know that I think don't you
yeah obviously that's why I said it
so you said it knowing it's racist
yes I fought fire with fire okay can I
hear to go hose down at least that's
only the type of freedom fighter that's
honest all right you were racist because
you knew it was racist but you decided
to do that because people have been
racist to you is that is that your
position no I'm not I first of all I
can't what is the beginning read the
whole tweet
I'm sure you have it in front of it
somebody in your office has it get him a
coffee and a yay tweet
what do you want to know the whole tweet
I want you to read it out loud sir I'm a
bit sleepy tonight but when I wake up
I'm going Defcon 3 on Jewish people the
funny thing is I actually can't be
anti-semitic because black people are
actually Jew also you guys are toy with
me and tried to blackball anyone who
opposes your agenda that was the exact
tweet
I like reading that whole thing I can't
be anti-semite I love Jewish people I
work with Jewish people yo watch this
watch this some of my best friends are
Jewish right so you know how that how
many times have you heard that statement
of course of course wait wait have we
ever heard that term before some of my
but the funny thing is they are I work
with Dove Charney that got kicked out of
his company out of American Apparel I
work with this guy every day he's like
my twin he's one of my favorite people
and the planet and we work through that
we talked through and he says yay why
are you so mad and I'm like this is why
I'm mad this contract right here what's
gonna happen before I'm done we're gonna
open up all of the music industry
contracts all of the publishing deals
all of the athlete deals all of the
acting deals all of the mortgages all of
the deals but that's fine but yeah
business people who we went at that's so
fun you can do it but it actually can
start somewhere of course you can do all
that and when you do that it has to
start somewhere I hope you won't be
judged as a black business person doing
it all the time that people don't phrase
it all the time by the color of your
skin but by your business Acumen isn't
that what you would like isn't that what
equality actually means
and of course I'll be judged by that
because when people come into power
people get judged you know I'm saying
like there's nobody that gets judged
more than a straight white male the
straight white male has the least amount
of a platform to even speak a straight
white male can't say my wife hurt me
today because people say well you're
hurting women a straight white male
can't say hey a black employee didn't
come in to work on time because then
people will say your race is a straight
white male can't speak on a homosexual
person because they'll say your home
you're homophobic and so I empathize
with the position
of the straight white male and part of
the reason why I empathize with that
position is because I know that I'm
headed to that position and what
position that it that is top power
position okay that's the top power
position where you get all the Rocks
thrown and that's that's the thing I
have friends right that will like
you know actually that's the reason why
I'm gonna be a good leader someday
because I'm really empathetic but I call
black people out on their stuff I call
white people out on their stuff because
we're all people we're actually only one
species and in order to whether it's my
friends texting me like bro you got to
get in the gym you're looking chubby in
the photo you know it's like we have to
hold
each other accountable to what's
actually happening and it's so much is
based on you did that tweet wrong so
what I will say is I feel that my words
demand more sensitivity for the
frequency that I'm operating at and that
and the amount of people that I'm
communicating to and I take that
responsibility right now but I will also
say everything happens for a reason
because if it had been perfectly worded
in English
and because there's nothing wider than
English itself right I'm already not
speaking in my mother tongue right so uh
if I had perfectly worded it and the
most sensitive way then we wouldn't be
here right now now we're opening up the
conversation like there I'm not allowed
to say whether or not I'm running for
office in 2024 but I'll tell you what if
the left let's say the left
the left would have never supported me
anyway
and now I've got to call to attention I
am who you should support the left did
not allow Trump to be president they
treated him like he wasn't even the
president so even then he won he was
losing half of the American people every
day and it divided the country what I'm
saying whoever goes into office for uh
British media for American Media we must
support our leaders and not just run
this hyper negative you know what I will
uh and black people hate when I
apologize for this when I see people
like John Legend and Chrissy Teigen talk
down on the president I'm like wow that
kind of sounds like me that kind of
sounds like the Telethon I opened up
this level of disrespect towards our
leaders and people are happy ah and the
left saw that and say well let's just
have every celebrity do what yay did at
the Telethon so I take responsibility
for that moment and you know what I just
want to give every Jewish person a big
hug also I'm envious of the Jewish
people I'm envious of how they don't
abort their children I'm envious of how
they don't shoot each other in the
streets and then rap about it I'm
envious of how their their families stay
together I'm envious that they turn
their phones off on Friday night and the
family comes together I'm envious of how
they do the business together and I want
that for the darker Jews I want that for
the black people I want that we need
that God said we should remove the word
want right we're going to have that and
this is the beginning of it but it seems
to me and correct me if I'm wrong but it
seems to me that you are acknowledging
as you've just acknowledged that it was
wrong to say what you said about
President Bush when he doesn't care
about black people that may have
encouraged all this disrespect towards
Presidents since I think it's an
interesting point you made it does seem
to me yay talking to you that even if
it's hard for you to admit this that you
do regret the wording of that tweet
which caused all the problems and you
wouldn't phrase it that way again am I
right
I would tell I would tell my dad that my
dad loved the White lives matter t-shirt
because what audacity does a black man
have to wear the exact same t-shirt that
a white man could wear you know and my
dad was a black panther I mean we have a
water purification Center you know he's
like the original Steve Jobs he's the
educated version of me right and he and
he liked both of those things but he
said you know yay he even calls me yay
now he's like Yay if you you've got to
be more sophisticated with your wording
and that wording like I said I'm a bit
sleepy and it lacked the sophistication
needed to be the true conductor that I
am because it's the conductor's job to
bring people together and that was
divisive which is not who I want to be
right so no so I'll tell you that I'm
not looking and also let me let me put
something you agree with me you know me
then
I want to I want to talk okay let me let
me show them I'm just thinking right now
so my heart is the idea for people who
do actually have severe mental health
issues you know the word [ __ ] for
you know there's parents that have
children who actually are mentally ill
and that word
is really offensive right to those
people so why use that and and just
because yeah just because I was I was
feeling
um
uh
uh what's a couple reasons because
people call me [ __ ] they treat me
like I'm [ __ ] uh and so I embrace it
it's like you call somebody so much they
say I'm
you call somebody a [ __ ] so much they
say I'm a [ __ ] you call somebody a
[ __ ] somebody should say I'm
[ __ ] like I was exhausted and I
embraced the idea
of having a serious mental health uh
issue but Noah I mean not Noah Noah also
but Moses was basically on speed when he
was doing what he did
out of Interest yeah how much sleep do
you get a night
I don't I I'm not here to talk about how
much sleep I get I don't literally just
been talking about how much sleep do you
how much sleep do you get in there I had
about five and a half hours last night
actually not very much
um but but you're the one that's raised
this issue and I probably had the same
right my question is that everybody had
the same but it's only because you've
been talking about you don't believe you
have a mental illness you think it's
lack of sleep so I think it's an obvious
question to ask well how much sleep do
you get do you are you constantly sleep
deprived is that is that one of the
reasons perhaps sometimes as you say you
feel sleepy and you shoot from the hip
verbally and you say stuff that maybe
when you're rested you wouldn't say it
the same way would that be fair tell me
what's
okay no it's not fair because what's
more important
the pain and the truth of what I'm
talking about and what led me to that
tweet or the Tweet itself
I think both can be true because the
problem you have is I think you've
acknowledge I think you've acknowledged
the words
yes I understand but the you know the
damage it caused and I think I
understand that that was offensive and I
think that you have accepted
no near no no you as a white person are
so stuck on the idea that what I said
was offensive which is a very caring
approach you're not sticking on the fact
you have not unpacked what happened with
those contracts I've said that but you
didn't ask me another question about it
that means there's an agenda absolutely
I have repeatedly said to you that I'm
sure I I do not disbelieve that you've
had contract business issues with
various managers accountants and so on
my argument is that when you just me or
other me I'm sure I'm sure many other
artists in the music business yeah of
course you know why you're sure because
because you don't care to do the
research because it doesn't affect you
no it's because you said you've done any
research no yeah let me explain to you
I'm not doubting what you don't care I
do care you don't care about me you
don't care about my people I care about
me I care about my people so as for me
to stand up and God forbid I step on
someone's toes while I'm at it it's not
some monsters you stepped on the entire
Jewish people's toes with a very deeply
inflammatory tweet which I think you've
now accepted you shouldn't have phrase
that way it's taken a bit of time to get
there but I think you have accepted that
right
have you accepted that you've put no
effort into understanding how I got
there
I don't think I don't think honestly 10
years from now honestly I don't think
there is apologize to me about this
interview you're gonna apologize to me
about this interview within the next 10
years no I'm not because here's the
thing my words I don't doubt you've had
it's very one-sided no it's not very
it's very white-sided
it's very like it's not white-sided I'm
not doubting you've had business issues
I'm saying the way to respond to that is
Jewish people millions of people
millions of people have had Defcon 3 on
their contracts right you didn't you
didn't say that you didn't say that said
millions of people well I open it up not
I didn't but now I'm saying it now okay
so now what I think you should say I
think you should say to the Jewish
people I'm sorry for the offensive
language I used in that tweet I wouldn't
do that again this is what I really
meant I think people would respect you
if you said that I don't know why you
can't just say that house let me you
know you know you know when I'll say it
when I sit down with the people who
write out the contracts for the NBA and
for the NFL and for professional music
and for uh acting contracts we need to
go to the top lawyers the top execs the
owners of the stadiums the owners of the
football teams and the owners of the
record labels and we're going to put
them all in one room and we're going to
read every dot let's go top 10 in each
one of these categories right let's read
Michael B Jordan why would any of those
okay why would any of that bro hey hey
bro I ain't finished I ain't finished my
sentence
hey boy don't finish I told you
oh don't treat me like a boy then I'm
gonna finish my sentence and my idea
nothing you're saying has got anything
to do with the Tweet cool
so I was in the middle of a sentence boy
okay so are you going to allow me to
finish my sentence yes
if you then answer my question Okay so
okay so I'm gonna tell people when I
would apologize for the tweet this is
what has to happen first
I need all of the top Executives in
Hollywood I need the top Executives at
the MBA and at the NFL we'll do those
two sports specifically and I want the
top Executives in music dealing with
publishing dealing with uh like Spotify
and apple music and uh Universal Music
and all the topics that uh let's do like
five topics X there and I want to look
at the top 10 earners and each one of
those fields contracts openly we want to
compare and contrast the contracts and
then once we open that conversation and
we need to do it on a platform live with
lawyers asking questions and we'll and
we'll have the top lawyers like a Johnny
Cochran Robert Kardashian level legal
team you know looking at all of these
contracts together after that moment
happens then I will say I'm sorry
okay if that's your position point of
view interview adjourned love you
so coming up yeah he's just back down
and interview gets even more explosive
as he opens up on Kim Kardashian Elon
Musk Vladimir Putin and more
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
welcome back to this special edition of
Piers Morgan on census from New York
Kanye West known as simply as yay 101
yay thanks for sitting back down I'll
change the subject now I mean I I just
get the feeling from you that you're
obviously a complex character brilliant
in many ways fascinating like I say
compelling uh you have a huge appeal to
millions of people around the world it
just seems to me that occasionally your
mouth gets you into trouble and that
perhaps on reflection sometimes you look
back and wish you hadn't said things is
that accurate
nah not really
because
the things I say are on behalf of God
like it's not always Godly because I'm a
man but God is definitely using me
are you you're you're you're uh Catholic
faith all right what's your background
Catholic yeah well we're we're working
for God here just like with black people
now with entertainment we're coming into
wealth but all the other you know black
people with anywhere near
uh my amount of wealth would never cross
the lines of you know taboos inside of
the media that I would that actually we
used to in rap all these words we used
to say these so it's all these like
words that are being removed from our
vocabulary words that evoke emotion
don't you feel like the salt is being
taken out of our our food you know look
at Dune the people who control the salt
controlled all the money and people are
trying to control the salt and it's salt
in our language that's why I'm I I will
not apologize for
uh having a bit of salt in my words I
will say hey this can be improved on but
it's like hey look I'm gonna update
you're looking at
the gods iPhone 100. we are God's iPhone
right if you think about it we're his
favorite creation we were made in His
image and we need updates and Society
capitalism media and thought police have
been stopping us from our updates think
about you know for
a homosexual kid
age 12 at school not wanting to say out
loud how he felt or feeling like if he
said how he felt he would get bullied or
what if he said how he felt and then
somebody said you said the way you felt
and what your experience was in the
wrong way now you need to apologize
we're fine that you felt that way but
you need to apologize for the way you
said it but just having the the courage
to do it in the first place would be you
know that's the thing that needs to be
given credit like yeah you know what
we'll say in these past two weeks I made
a big splash because the first time you
dive in the deep end you're not going to
look like an Olympic swimmer but we're
going to have to learn how to swim and
I've dived in the deep end okay I think
I understand what you're saying let me
ask you about your family yeah lots of
speculation of course constantly if if
you understand if you understand what
I'm saying could you translate what I'm
saying yes I want you to translate what
I said and then let's move on to the
next question okay let me attempt to try
what did I mean by that I think what she
meant was that you are not afraid to
ruffle feathers you're not afraid to
cause trouble where you feel it's
Justified you're not afraid to call
people out who you think deserve to be
called out but occasionally
you've expressed yourself in a way that
perhaps hasn't quite hit the right Mark
and that you are work in progress as
indeed we all are and that you could
phrase things better which would cause
less offense to a wider number of people
when in fact the target of your anger
may be much more specific that would be
my interpretation of what you've just
said
do you think that we can move forward as
a civilization without there being any
offense because one person's truth can
be the other person's lie
part of me wants to say yes to that but
I do think there is a line and we should
all be mindful of the line and the line
to me is I don't think any form of
racism or perceived racism should ever
be tolerated I don't think that is free
speech it's just hate speech and I think
one of the problems with what you said
about the Jewish people was the more
generic way that you phrase that
sentence people didn't understand you
were talking about specific business
people you'd had a problem with they
thought you genuinely meant you were
going Defcon 3 on all Jewish people and
they took that to be a blatant form of
anti-Semitism I think you've explained
in this interview that was not your
intention at all which is good but I
think if you're asking me to interpret
what you've just said yourself that
would be my interpretation that you know
your your work in progress and sometimes
you say stuff I didn't just it doesn't
quite doesn't quite it doesn't quite get
over what you're really meaning
but what I really mean is I don't want
it to be settled I don't want I I don't
want uh I don't want to be forgiven by
Jewish people until we get to what the
problem really is I don't want you know
like Elon he got on Twitter he said I
talked to yay took it to heart and I
liked my boy standing up for me but I
was like but my the fight isn't done
though everybody White media left media
they just want to squash the fight they
want to keep the pain of George Floyd
going right but they don't want the pain
of our Representatives what did Elon
Musk say to you about Jewish business
out of Interest
it's vague to me right now I don't want
to misquote them what was it just say to
me what was the General point of what he
was saying
it's vague to me it's truly vague to me
you know I'm an honest person I tell you
what it was but I keep on saying it's
just always about this tweet it's so
much more if you if you look back at
this energy at this interview and it's
like a direction arrow
it's more in the direction of fixing the
statement than fixing the problem I
think that's my problem I understand but
I would say to that I think they're two
different things and you can fix both
actually uh and I I accept that part of
what you were trying to do and the point
you were trying to make I completely
understand it because you've explained
it in more detail on Elon Musk there is
a suggestion that when he gets control
of Twitter which seems likely now that
he will bring you back you'll bring
Donald Trump back do you think that
would be right
it'll be lit
do you think it's wrong that you and
Trump have been have been banned from
these platforms
absolutely I was talking to Trump a
couple days ago and he was like I'm not
going to do his voice right but he was
saying uh
you know I had 277 million followers and
the next day I had nothing and that
related to
you know Mark Zuckerberg meta you know
Mark Zuckerberg thinks he is the
government these tech companies feel
they're more powerful
than the US government to the point of
actually kicking the actual president of
the United States off of an American
social media platform this is the world
we live in
and I would say I listen to that I agree
with you and I'll tell you why I I think
it's completely inconsistent that
companies like Facebook and Twitter
allow people like the Ayatollah of Iran
for example to remain on the platform or
Taliban people to be on the platform but
they don't allow an American president
that seems to me completely ludicrous
yes and this is part of the 100 year
plan that they have books on about
uh you know China's takeover of America
after losing the Industrial Revolution
now let's talk about business people we
won't refer to their race and by the way
I'll tell you as a Jew person a person
that has a lot of Jewish friends it's
not a race it's a people right and every
Jewish every Jewish homeboy I know is
going to be like yo yeah that's right so
um
uh but it's hard
to attract it's it's hard to influence
patriotism on capitalists
and it's a responsibility for us as
Americans to retake our power in Media
to retake our power in our schools to
retake our power and our Farms to retake
our power and our medicine and our
hospitals
to revitalize the country because
America invented rock and roll at the
end of the day we have the inventions
America created Apple you understand
like we created the platforms that the
world uh that the world runs on now and
we've allowed the business people in
these companies to sell us and whatever
the term is sell them in a handbag
whatever it is for cheap and Americans
are God-fearing for the most part
God-fearing Christian people and we're
not cheap
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
I want to ask you about your family yeah
because you mentioned families there a
lot of stuff has been written about you
and your family uh a lot of it fueled by
you by Kim by others where are things
now with your family what is what is
your relationship like with Kim with
your kids
Kim has
zionists media handlers
surrounding her all in and out her Hulu
TV show all in and out her her family
all in or out the house that I created
for my family but God is alive the Devil
is a defeated Foe and Kim is a Christian
woman and she's not here just to have
content up on adult channels she's not
here just to have that last interview
magazine cover if you look at the two
interview magazine covers look at the
one when I was there and look at the one
when I'm not there and that's the reason
why this Tuskegee experiment of such
that's happened to the black community
where they took the fathers out of the
home and the leaders out of the
community and have torn apart the
community now they've seen that's worked
and they're doing that to America
they're attempting they're trying I mean
that interview the interview the
interview magazine cover you're talking
about I think is the one where she was
basically semi-naked in front of the
American flag and I thought that was
pretty distasteful actually
it was about the American dream and I
thought well if that's the American
dream we're all screwed and I and I
agree with that and I I didn't feel the
platform to voice my opinion because I
wanna it's always like hey this is your
kid's mother this year but it's time
with the leaders like I'm still the
priest of that home Chris I'm still the
priest of that home
they they want to make it this matriarch
Society all that and you know but I am
the priest of this home and God is alive
I am the living Robert Kardashian and
I'm gonna stand up for what God would
want as a Christian and then people say
as a Christian or you're not supposed to
curse you're not supposed to have
righteous indignation but I do you know
Christians had swords also Christians
got guns I tell you that you know so but
do you talk to you talk to him there
have been reports here that you and Kim
don't really talk at the moment she's
distancing herself from me because of
the stuff you've been saying was getting
controversy is that true
I mean John Legend is distant distancing
my himself from me and buying more
Christmas sweaters in the middle of
spring also so I'm not saying that you
know they're making the right decisions
uh she's being influenced you know but I
guarantee you what's not gonna happen
we're not going to seeing one of them
John Legend Christmas sweaters no time
soon but do you talk to her are you
still in touch wait a minute don't you
think it's like don't you think it's
like funny to like make a joke out of
stuff sometimes don't you think like God
has a sense of humor gosh but watch this
God God when I got married I bought this
house I like you know what I'm saying I
did this tour and spent all the money I
had on this house to like surprise Kim
and give her this house that she wanted
that Lisa Marie Presley used to own and
um and then I got the house and then I
put all this money into renovation and
then there goes the neighborhood Drake
moves down the street five blocks and
that's when I knew God was funny but
watch this is where God is even funnier
here goes like Louis CK part two level
because Louis CK is the funniest man
alive uncancel him now right
sorry are you sad that you're no longer
together that you're divorced
we'll always be together
she dresses exactly like me what do you
mean like my kids are me you know
there's no person that she'll ever get
with that will influence her more than
God and then her priest on Earth which
is me you know whether it's the the
skims clothing line the designers the
The Architects all those people you got
the clintons the left
utilizing what we built together to try
to use her as an influence for the black
culture and this word culture in general
for the next elections they need those
300 million followers from Kylie and Kim
on their side going into their election
as they push trauma culture to the black
people again as they claim anything any
of my questions of business dealings to
be anti-semitic comments and push you
know Kim to you know as a billionaire
mother of a lawyer and a mother of four
Jew black children
uh
uh to do covers like interview and
that's what happens when they take the
dads out the home and that's what
they've been doing in the hood they take
the fathers and the leaders out of the
homes like when I was young and I would
go to the video store if I wanted to go
into the adult section it was a curtain
it was a person sitting there watching
making sure that kids didn't go in if
the kids went into that section there
was a video camera and they would have
you be escorted out of that section now
that section is forced through Tick Tock
and in so many branded commercials to
confuse children and to sexualize our
children way too early yeah of course
they can even make their own decisions
about their life look you make some very
interesting points again just to clarify
one thing though you are actually
divorced are you because my
understanding was that you weren't
actually divorced yet
you know I asked God the same question
some mornings
am I divorced God am I am I divorced
because
I might be divorced on paper but I'm not
divorced of the idea of being the
protector of not only this person who is
so influential imagine Kim
making all of her decisions that she
does publicly you know grown folks
businesses grown folks business never
know what could happen with a little
sippy sippy or whatever but you know all
the decisions that she makes publicly
being based on an audience of one and
Pierce what audience do you think I'm
saying that is well you mean God
God so picture the most influential
person
on the planet the most influential woman
on the planet
performing in public only for that
audience of one for God imagine the
overwhelmingly positive effect that that
will have on the planet and
Mark these words it will happen someday
okay and I had this thing I had this
like you know of course I'm I'm a
divorced and this is like a a funny
thing I thought being that her name is
no longer West
and my name is no longer yay if there
was ever I mean sorry being that her
name is no longer West and my name is
now only yea if we were ever to be
together again what would our name be
kimye
would you like that
everything is up to God and God
has proven to me
many times that it's not about what I
want or what I would like
it's just up
to him
on what he sees
fit but you know David let me ask you I
mean do you still love the Sheep sorry
not for the S do you still love Kim
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
this is talk TV
[Music]
do you still love Kim
I absolutely love I love her for life
and I'll pray and I will protect oddly
enough I'll actually protect her because
when I call out things that I feel are
wrong
you know what I'm saying when I make
products like say the difference between
me and Bernard are no
like say watch Elon Musk every product
the reason why Elon Musk is like a Steve
Jobs is
if he makes a flamethrower he would use
that flamethrower if he makes a cyber
truck he would use that cyber truck me
if I make some 3D printed boots you know
I'm gonna have the the 3D printed boots
on Wow every day
absolutely sir
These Boots Are a hit love those yes
those are fantastic would you like one
day to get back with Kim do you think do
you feel like you've gone through a very
tumultuous period but actually the love
Underneath It All between two people
remains and would you like to get back
together
those thirst traps still be fire
is that so do you understand what I said
do you understand that language I think
so you better explain it explain it to
me
what do you think those thirst traps
still be fire means can you explain that
to me well with my uh rather
straps still be fire I would imagine it
means he's a brilliant British man I
would imagine it means you still fancy
or what your ex-wife is that right
you know I I would prefer to not be put
on this uh uh I would never I would
prefer to not be put
on the spot
uh on these kind of questions what I can
say is
uh God is a God is alive God had David
tend to the Sheep knowing that one day
he would prepare him to fight Goliath
so I believe that that day of me
fighting Goliath has been this
past two weeks the media is Goliath
and there would be no chance of having a
civil civilization or civil
uh Democracy in America without me
challenging the media two years out from
the election
because this thing that I'm challenging
may be setting myself up to one day be
able to be president or it's uh maybe
for the other president but regardless
we have to have some decency in America
as the thought leaders and the content
that we put out but yeah
on that point you keep talking about the
media as if somehow it's the media
that's created all this Fury in the last
two weeks but you have said other things
which in my opinion the media couldn't
ignore you know you suggested in your
interview with Tucker Carlson the gap
for example the clothing wear company
had prior knowledge of the a validate
shooting which is obviously completely
insane
why would you say that and then why
would you be surprised at the media if
the media then react to it about it
what I'm saying is that was worded
that might have been worded in a way
that the media could take in the wrong
way
but I thought it was really interesting
the amount of people that Gap
we had we had a release that was
happening and the amount of people at
Gap
that were rallying around this as a
media moment if they didn't know
about that where there's theories you
can't say that the theory is about 9 11
are completely insane
actually that's just the person kind of
person well look you're perfectly
entitled to have theories I think most
of them are completely insane
specific one yeah on your valve day you
even suggested that Matthew McConaughey
right he was suggested that Matthew
McConaughey may have it was all a bit
weird that he was speaking so early
about it when in fact he came from a
validate and spoke very passionately
after this atrocity
so I think people read these comments
are like what are you talking about
no okay so I'm not
what I'm saying
is
I definitely feel there is a major media
push around that to create trauma and
fear culture 20 kids were shot dead in
the club in a classroom 20 children were
shot dead in school so let me explain no
one of the media is put in how many any
sort of trauma into that that is the
trauma
okay Pierce Pierce how many how often
does that happen in my hometown
well 20 kids are killed in school in one
mass shooting as far as I'm aware it's
never happened in your hometown has it
every
yeah it does and it's not in one match
shooting killed in Chicago I didn't
finish I didn't finish okay let's not do
this again okay we reviewed I understand
you could talk at least
at least 14 kids are killed in Chicago
every week and there's no media push
around it and that's my issue and I was
at Gap there was no media push around
the killings in Chicago I completely
agree my youngest son has recently been
at University of Chicago every year and
there were two students shot in that
time I completely agree that there is
never enough attention given to all the
slaughter from gun violence in Chicago
completely agree with you what I can't
agree with is any suggestion by you that
anyone at Gap or Matthew McConaughey or
anybody else had any prior knowledge and
what happened to davalde of course they
didn't
what I'm saying is I'm not saying they
did but with the amount of tension that
went understand I was jealous once again
you feel me I'm jealous that so much
attention went
in this direction but doesn't go into
the direction of Chicago
amount of people that's what you should
say yeah but it comes down to the way
you freeze it bro bro hey hey I just
said it yeah like I just said you're not
always going to say the things the right
way but at least I have The Bravery to
open the conversation your first your
first sentence isn't your last sentence
my first rap that I told wasn't my last
rap that I told and now that's the whole
point it said once it said except that
it was said I am the iPhone 20 right
have you ever heard the term
premeditated murder yes
I I feel I feel like
the George Floyd was a premeditated
murder that's my feeling based off of I
agree but not for the reason you think I
think it was premeditated in the sense
that that policeman didn't give a damn
about George Floyd's life stuck his knee
on his neck for eight minutes and killed
him like I said the opportunity like I
said it different ways like I said to
you you are completely entitled to
challenge anything frankly and I'm
equally entitled to come back to you and
say what I think that is a democracy is
about next tonight my world exclusive
interview with yay continues
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I genuinely mean it when I say I think
you're one of the most brilliant
talented people that I've seen in the
public sphere and you have a lot of
fascelling ideas and you're incredibly
creative and you're completely entitled
to your views but I'm entitled to mine
and I think we've had some really uh
really interesting exchanges actually I
want to just talk to you quickly before
we finish about your kids and about you
as a father what kind of kids do you
want them to be what kind of values do
you want to instill in your children
I want my kids to finish their education
I know that my album was called The
College Dropout but when I look at the
way
you know just like like you said your
kids are in the University of Chicago we
need the education that's another thing
to be jealous about you know the the
Muslims have the Quran right and Jewish
people also have their uh their holy
books but they have
the education
and once we have the education the
education and we have the the strong
black uh Minds we need to pull them
together there hasn't been end-to-end
black owned communities since Black Wall
Street or since the gentrification of
Harlem like I was talking I have this
tech company called stem right so I call
this guy and we're working on finishing
up elements of the deal and he's using
emotional bullying and like his
shoulders are down you could tell on the
call he says well because of your
comments we're not going to be able to
hire people uh it's the people that we
need and I said well well how many
people do we have working for us he said
60 and we have 40 part-time I said well
how many Jewish people do we have he
said well I don't know I don't know will
you have some and I said well do we have
black people working for he said yeah I
said how many he said two
and I said you're telling me we can't
find 60 black Engineers well yeah and
see that's where that comment that got
me into so much trouble forced me to
look at myself as a black as the richest
black man since Manson Moon so right
with multiple tech companies and where
am I kicking the tires inside of my own
company to ensure that I'm hiring my
people because Chinese people hire
Chinese people and Jewish people hire
Jewish people and Catholics hire
Catholics right but with blacks we'll
give our company to uh Bernard our no
we'll give our company to Mark
Zuckerberg we'll give our company away
you know Kamala is our never again we're
never gonna just hand something over
just because we like the way this person
looks and we have the emotional
connection because she was a Delta and
my mom was a Delta she got 96 of the
black female vote you would have thought
Drake was running and we haven't seen
her really honestly since
and yeah I want to say something about
the left the left you guys got to sit
with me your current Administration that
these guys put up they they they eat the
pot on this one they should have got
Bernie but Bernie had too much of a
conscience and so you got a guy with no
conscience instead of getting Bernie
Sanders you guys got Weekend at Bernie's
I want to disagree with you about it I
don't disagree with you about President
Biden
um for that matter let me ask you about
someone we haven't mentioned Vladimir
Putin and what he's been doing in
Ukraine what is your view of that
I
do not believe in war
and I believe
that there is ways that America could
have avoided
this war
but
Biden has money Biden has reasons for us
to be at War right now for selfish
reasons and what I would like to do
without giving you too much information
I would like to speak with my political
advisors to give you the exact
uh exact information I'm not gonna hey
watch this one pierce I'm not gonna
shoot from the hip on this one
especially talking about war and things
as sensitive as Ukraine and the Russian
war no no you we already got that um the
[ __ ] comment earlier that we could
work on that I feel like is going to be
massively offensive and I really do all
right now that one I do apologize to
people that I offended earlier in the
interview on that comment maybe we could
look at scrubbing that if we if we if we
deem well actually actually I would say
I would say this it's an uncensored
interview you said something which
you've now wished you hadn't said and
you've apologized I actually think that
says a lot about you right that shows
you've got that ability to be self-aware
to understand when you cross a line I
think someone like you with all your
energy and creativity and your passion
you're gonna say stuff the way that you
talk constantly and in such an
extraordinary manner you're gonna trip
part you're going to say things the
wrong way I don't think there's anything
wrong and when you do that doing what
you just did and saying I'm sorry I
crossed a line I apologize it's actually
quite empowering
do you
you know what I think you know what I
think I'll go ahead and do
I feel that I've given the platform and
I think by holding the idea of an
apology hostage is not Godlike correct I
feel like we have to free
yeah you know and I think that's the
point that you've been making and
because we sat down and had this
conversation
you know
I will say I'm sorry for the people that
I heard with the Defcon the the
confusion that I call I feel like I call
I cause hurt and confusion and I'm sorry
for the families of the people that had
nothing to do with the the trauma that I
had been through and that I use my
platform where you say hurt people hurt
people and I I was hurt I was frustrated
and I want to say that it's wrong to
hold an apology hostage and I gotta let
go of that and free you know free myself
of the trauma and say look I'm just
gonna give it all up to God right now
and say to those families that I heard
you know I really want to give you guys
a big hug and I want to uh I say I'm
sorry for hurting you with my comments
and I want to word it and not a pres and
not like a political way but in a
presidential way which means what I knew
a president to be when I was growing up
and a sincere way you know how people
give those kind of I want to give an
apology and you're like but did you you
know what I'm saying like no it has to
be I want to go to every person's
grandmother and grandfather
and every person's son and daughter aunt
and uncle and give them a hug and say
you know what I've been hurt
and I do want you to talk to your voice
I do want you to talk to the people that
are in power the people who do own the
black voice the people who do own the
black void the vote which a lot of
Jewish business people do and I I want
to be able to sit at the table with the
contracts I want my people to sit at the
table with the contracts I do want all
of this but I'm not going to hold my
apology hostage till I get that I'm
going to start by taking accountability
from my actions and the lack of
sophistication in my wording like I said
I was sleepy and it was taken
and in a way that I didn't mean to me to
be taken it definitely caused some
attention but I don't want the
conversation to go away just because I
came to you guys and said you know I
understand how I hurt you and I'm sorry
for the pain that I've caused and the
confusion that I cause now that is said
right but I don't want the conversation
to go away that we are still in a place
where these contracts are still
my people are still getting screwed this
has to be opened up and I'm not asking
for a promise but it would be a
beautiful world as as I release the pain
that I've caused and the pain that I
have in me that Grudge that I was
holding that you guys some of you guys
one two of you guys step up and say
let's look at these contracts let's make
it not be a known fact that the music
industry is treacherous let's make it
because my kids so my kids do music you
know I don't want them to step into a
treacherous place I wanted to be better
for them than it was for me so I want us
to sit down and come together and really
work on that what would that make sense
to you pierce you know what you ate if
you'd simply said that in your tweet I
don't think there would have been any
problem and I'm very very pleased
actually that we've got to a place where
you felt able to say that and I think it
was sincere but we still have a problem
what's my point I get it I get it but
what you've now done you've now
explained the context of the problem and
you also issued a sincere apology to
people who were rightly offended by the
way you phrased what you said so I think
that's a that's a good place to finish
the interview and I I'm very glad you
got there
okay but it's not finished I understand
ideas not finished I understand that
there's that there's still a problem I
understand no one's going to be in any
doubt there's a problem and by the way
I'm sure there is I'm sure that a lot of
the contracts in the music business are
rigged against people uh like like
artists like yourself I'm sure of it
it's always been the case from Elvis yes
so I I guess would you would you would
you help me and my people would you help
me and my my athletes I got so many
athletes that go to my school that are
like all the guys that are on down there
are headed to the NBA right could you
help me could you help us make these
contracts better for our people by call
calling attention by just allowing me on
your platform right and let's look at
some of the things and point these
things out could could we work together
absolutely happy in the Years very happy
to do that yeah very happy to do that I
think we should talk more often all
right it's taken a long time to get here
I've thoroughly enjoyed our conversation
it's been two hours it's been free
rolling been occasionally challenging
but we've got to a place where I think
it's a good place and I really enjoyed
it so thank you very much indeedia for
sparing me the time yeah
you know you know I'm going to feel like
a lot I I lost my stone I was holding
yeah
yeah but but I but I had to give it up
to God you know what I'm saying like yes
uh you know you're going to be bragging
you're going to be bragging at dinner
tonight like yo I talked to yay no one
could do it no one could do it I did it
and you know
I'm I'm I'm giving you this and I'm
gonna pray that you as a fellow believer
in Christ will help me to expose all the
wrong that's still currently happening
to my people specifically in the
entertainment industry because honestly
I'm very happy to start with I'm very
happy to hold anyone's account who is
behaving improperly honestly and I'm I'm
absolutely certain that that
entertainment business is riddled with
people who try it on and exploit people
and I'll be very happy to help you to
expose that but for now I've got to
leave it yay we've had two hours it's
been remarkable thank you very much for
your time
peace well that's super Delight an
extraordinary interview whatever you're
up to keep it uncensored
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you